hey guys welcome back to the park which
is now officially called Cydonia hills
and i want to talk about this a little
bit and also a couple of other things
which i did post in the description of
the last video but didn't actually talk
about in the video itself so first of
all i want to talk about the name change
for a little bit this park was called
Raptor land in the series but I decided
to call it Cydonia hills in the end
since the original save game was called
Cydonia hills which was just a project
name I was listening to Knights of
Cydonia when I had to save this park
just because I have to save it to open
it later and I really didn't want to
spend too much time on it at the time
such as quickly saved it under Cydonia
hills but since it's been added to the
game on the steam release which is
really awesome but yeah since that
happened
it's basically become known as sedona
hills and i didn't quite like the
reptile ant name anyway so ditched that
in favor of Cydonia hills but yeah
that's why there was a bit of confusion
when it comes to that and also another
thing i want to quickly say is I want to
thank Gordon a lot for giving me the
music files of the game so I can use
them as background music for these
videos because I was pretty cheap when I
bought pike texts at first and then buy
the soundtrack tier so I couldn't really
use the soundtrack to make videos with
but then going and actually offered to
give me the soundtrack just for the
video so that's why we can actually
listen to it in the video is now and
there's also one other thing basically
up to this point all of these videos
have been recorded quite a long time ago
and it's about two months ago at this
point which is a really long time and a
very long time to before the the Steam
version of the game was actually
released this park was made initially
for the trailers so the Imagineer and
the Big Brother trailers and other stuff
that might be coming down the pipe as we
speak so it's been quite a while since I
was making this and I was only very
recently got back into it hands also why
this park was unfinished when you got it
into park attacks if you have the steam
version of the game and hands also why
there's quite a time gap between me
making this section of the park and the
second half of the park
I'm going to start making in the second
half of this video so that's just
something to keep in mind anyway to
actually talk about this part of the
park for a little bit I wanted to make
the roman section of the park in this
episode not really because I have any
sort of planning for it I mean I really
don't even have any kind of planning for
this entire park and I'm just making
stuff up as I go along and just testing
all sorts of stuff and I really felt
like I wanted to test the Roman theme
since it seemed pretty feasible with all
of the different pillar and detail items
that were in the game at this point and
it just seemed like a rather easy thing
to do since you don't need any specific
details to really make it happen and
hence also why I wanted to build it like
this and set up this general area in a
quite grid like way much like the Forum
Romanum which I took quite some
inspiration from to have this Gravitron
Gravitron well no it's not a Gravitron
that's the RCT name for it's like this
French thing which I can't pronounce but
the this sort of triple topspin which is
really awesome but confusing right but
it's also really large and I felt it
would be best to also have like this
large facade as a as an arm really
around the ride much in a form Romanum
kind of way as you had on the old plaza
and the centre of Asian ancient Rome
hence also why the buildings are
somewhat inspired by it's the first
temple kind of building was just heavily
inspired by the temple of Saturn in the
forum in Rome and there will also be a
small Basilica type building and there's
of course the very Roman gallery which
runs alongside the right just to make it
offer you a little bit more urban rather
than just having trees all around it and
yeah I just felt like I wanted to do it
that way I also want to keep as little
space open with just trees and general
foliage in the park but fill it as much
as I can with rides paths and buildings
which is also more or less part of the
aesthetic that I'm trying to get in this
park where it's not entirely a realistic
park
I'm completely leaving out the more
realistic partly how it's to be honest
and some of the realism aspects like
actually having backs to all of these
buildings and backstage areas or a more
realistic way of just making general
areas because I also want to keep that
sort of old rollercoaster tycoon or
theme park world of you even will sort
of appeal to the look of this park so
actually took a lot of inspiration also
from the old roller coaster coding
scenarios and some of the way that the
ways that these Six Flags parks in
roller coaster going to are laid out as
well and I know I've been making the
comparison with roller coaster tycoon a
lot when I talk about this game but it's
just something where I don't feel it's a
complete copy of it it definitely isn't
and it's got many unique aspects as well
but it's just it has a certain similar
appeal and at least to me I feel that
other of those just a certain value of
nostalgia when I play this game and it's
also why I felt it would be quite quite
nice to make a park which in a way sort
of recreates or tries to recreate this
vibe that the old roller coaster [ __ ]
games had because truth be told they're
just my favorite games of all time and
I'm actually really happy with how much
this game is actually living up to it at
this point so as much as I make it may
make it sound like a ripoff sometimes I
I think for me especially its kind of a
compliment to the game as well anyway
moving on I was actually originally
planning to have a Japanese area where I
just made that bit of terraforming but I
won't actually do it I am going to move
the Japanese area actually a bit further
down the park to make some room for a
larger Roman area than what I was
planning at the moment here because I
don't really know too many other
different themes for the park so I'm
going to go with a outline team and the
Roman theme we should already have
then have a slightly larger Japanese
theme than I was originally planning and
then one part of the park is still left
open for a different theme which I'm not
really sure entirely what I'm going to
try for that and it's got to be pretty
tough to come up with something as well
that'll be quite simple and still using
all of the vanilla pieces but still be a
very recognizable theme but that's
something to really worry about in the
in the past and also to make the park
actually live up to its name because
it's now called Cydonia hills I should
probably also incorporate a few more
Hills than I've currently been doing
because it doesn't really make much
sense to have a park altered on your
hills without any hills so that's also
something I want to get into a little
bit more I also feel I'll probably get a
bit better at the game while I work my
way through this park and especially the
isometric way of looking at it and
making a park because there isn't quite
so much while there isn't quite so much
interaction between different heights
and levels so there aren't really many
paths going over each other or coasters
diving underneath paths and going over
them there's not a lot of terraforming
in the park at the moment and that's
also something that I do want to get
into a little bit further because really
terraforming and having all of these
parts of the park just go over and
underneath each other just makes it look
more interesting since you're viewing it
from an isometric perspective and I
choose something that I haven't really
been getting into so far in the series
aside from just having these small
elements like the exit paths of the
chess wing and the carousel go over
different paths and having that small
river alongside the Main Street but I
think there is still a lot more that I
can do in that respect and actually make
it a bit more interesting from the
isometric perspective in that way that's
something I want to get into also I have
actually seen many people get yeah some
troubles running this park in park texts
and that's probably something I should
address because the frame rate when you
open this park is not that great it
isn't for me but it also apparently
isn't for many people playing the game
and I'm actually googled the park and
found quite a number of people actually
complaining about
FPS when you play this bike and I do
also have to say that the developers
originally also said that this was quite
a good Pike to test the performance of
the game with since there's such a well
pretty bad level of detail in this park
weathers especially so much grass and
small rock pieces everywhere but yeah
precisely because of that it doesn't
really run very well and I think the
main culprit is the grass which has also
been slightly changed since like the
grass disappears if you zoom out a
little but still the performance of this
park isn't that great at this point and
should also definitely improve probably
as the game develops because it's still
an alpha but yeah that's just something
to keep in mind if you do open this park
or at least the unfinished state at the
moment in your game it's gonna not run
very well probably just because there's
quite a high level of detail in the park
now that said this is the second half of
the video so it's been nearly yeah I
think it's been nearly two months I
think it's been six weeks since I last
worked on it where I got back to the
park yesterday and I'm working on it
again and this is when I also wanted to
add some extra details because as you
can see this is the first time I am
actually working on this Park in the
Alpha so there's a bunch of new stuff
and also some new planters and things
like that also special thanks for
actually making the planters possible to
be placed on paths because that was one
of my requests actually and it got put
in the game which is pretty cool so yeah
I'm actually gonna probably get back to
a lot of the planter stuff and add some
extra detail to the park to the part of
the park which I've already built
because there's just a bit more detail
to be added just sprucing up the parks
depart
little scenery items on them like some
small planters and stuff like that to
make it look a little bit more
interesting than just the antique pots
which I currently have but aside from
that's not too many big changes are
there and I'm not sure what coaster
types I'll really get to in the rest of
the park because as I said there is no
planning whatsoever in this park and I'm
really just winging it and
truth be told not even playing it that
seriously either it's just mostly
enjoying and just kind of playing it for
fun here so I'm not really sure if I'll
get into the the most new attractions
and the recent additions to the game
when it comes to coaster types but yeah
we'll see in the future really because I
have no exact plans for coasters to be
added in the future so yeah the the fact
that I'm playing in the new alpha now
doesn't really make too much of a
difference to the rest of the park
generally aside from just a couple extra
bushes and planters and stuff like that
though I think I might want to make a
bnm inverted coaster in the Japanese
area because that seems like a lot of
fun and something that would work really
well with the theme and terraforming as
well because terrain coasters are just
one of my favorite types of coasters or
if not my favorite it's not really a
type but terrain inverts are really
amazing so I might get into that in the
Japanese theme but then again I have no
idea quite yet what I'm gonna do with
that eventually in the rest of the Roman
area though and I'm really just quickly
finishing this small path over here it
was really like a little forest area and
originally I intended it as a like
transition between the future Japanese
area and the rest and the Roman area
which I had but now I figured the Roman
area is pretty small so I might as well
extended a bit make that Street more
part of the area and add another pretty
large section of the Roman area with a
new ride and that's what I wanted to
talk about because I am adding a log
flume over here which is also very
escape from Pompeii ish type of thing
and it's quite standard at this point to
have a classical theme with log flume or
other types of water rides but I just
felt it would work pretty well with the
Roman theme here and just be a very good
occasion to try and mess around with
different types of facades and making
this large blob of scenery for the log
flume to interact with and also have a
nice little like walkway Boulevard type
thing with the paths alongside this
small lake that the log flume creates
and have some Roman buildings alongside
that to have a bit more interaction with
the water
in the parts and the log flume itself as
well as the scenery around it so yeah
that's the general idea of this though
it can probably be boiled down to being
a ripoff of escape from Pompeii if you
will it's also going to be most
resembling a real theme park area I
think since it doesn't just take a lot
of inspiration from escape from Pompeii
I think it's it also resembles the
Atlantic a super splash area a little
bit in the general way it's laid out and
perhaps also the area next to furious
Parker in Port Aventura and having that
walkway alongside the water with all
these Italian like buildings alongside
it and it's gonna be quite an open area
with having that lake in the middle and
it's definitely going to be one of the
if not the most heavily themed parts of
the park so far and I won't actually be
able to completely finish it in this
episode I'll just be working on the
string of buildings alongside this part
of the lake and then get into the large
rock with all sorts of facades that the
log flume itself goes through at the top
of the lift Hills in the next episode
and also some other facades and probably
the transition into the Japanese area
though I'm not entirely sure if I'll
actually be able to have enough time
left to start work on the Japanese area
in the next episode already so I'll
probably be just tying up the loose ends
of the Roman area in the next episode
and maybe make a quick starts on the
Japanese part of the park also the
buildings on the string of facade are
really unplanned and not with any type
of central idea or function so their
village is there to create a general
atmosphere and make it all come together
but not really with any specific type of
function I might make a restaurant of
this building specifically though it's
very restaurant ish it's also a lot more
I should say there is a bit of a very
subtle difference in the two parts of
the Roman area because obviously the
Roman area really consists of two main
squares almost with a a sort of
connecting street between them and the
older parts is really much more like the
four
remaining with having new temples and
more of the like official Roman
architecture and the newer part with the
log flume is a little bit more like just
some smaller houses I still want to just
keep some of the temple like designs in
there because they're generally the most
recognizable kind of Roman architecture
and probably also most feasible to do
with the items currently in the game but
there's a I feel a very subtle
difference in the way that both sides of
the area are made obviously of course
though the universe Aria is also made
with a little bit more experience and
quite a while later and with the newer
version of the games to that place alone
a little bit as well also this recording
is so much better when it's not past
with all the people just walking around
which is something I should probably
shouldn't talk about but I think it
works a lot better just playing it also
the trees swaying is absolutely amazing
but yeah that's all about that I also
did want to come back to some of the
other parts of the park as you just saw
to just add a couple new things in some
of those new planters and those new
bushes which lit got put into the game
which are really versatile like some of
those smaller things which you can dress
up the smaller parts of your park a
little bit more and add some extra
detailing and so I also really wanted to
just get back to the older areas of the
park and add that a little bit more now
coming to the station of the log flume
it's a pretty simple design I actually
wanted to lay off using the red roofs
because it's a very overused thing at
this point and I felt it would be a
little nicer perhaps to go with a more
Greek temple like roof which is maybe a
little more boring and not as
interesting of the building itself but
helps to differentiate I feel the
station building from the rest of the
scenery buildings and I kind of wanted
to avoid having every single building
have the same red roof so I just wanted
to try something a little bit different
with this roof and also have that small
overhang on the front there to make it
not look like such a boxy building
because one of the biggest pitfalls I
find with stations is make them complete
rectangles which can be somewhat
interesting but I generally find it's
much more interesting to look at a
station with a
some parts sticking out or some more
interaction with its environment because
one of the main reasons why I am so
afraid of making rectangular stations is
it's hard to place it in their general
area and just by having that small
overhang and a small little parts
alongside the water there I wanted to
make it a little bit closer to the lake
and to the rest of the ride as well and
also something about the topic of the
roofs and things like that every single
red roof or nearly every single red roof
for these buildings has a slightly
different shade of red so there are some
very different subtle differences in the
tones of the colors which isn't that big
of deal but just also one of the things
I wanted to do here just to make the
buildings look a little bit different
even though they have generally the same
colors and the same details that I used
to make them and the same really goes
for the walls and windows and other
pieces like pillars as well there are
some slightly different tones and shades
of colors used in the buildings in that
way too and the last building I just
wanted to have over here is actually
going to be a functional building unlike
the other ones at least at the moment I
may well give a function to the other
buildings as well maybe just some small
restaurants it's kind of a shame I can't
really dress them up as restaurants not
being able to use shyguys sets because
this is a vanilla park but still I might
want to give some sort of function to
some of these buildings but I don't want
to do it too much since I have a lot of
buildings in the park at the moment and
I feel like realistically I should have
stalls and things like that in every
single building that I built but it's
something that I might also get back to
you in the future because truth be told
there are quite some stalls to be used
to and it's probably a lot more fun to
at least have some more stalls than just
having empty buildings all over the
place so I'll probably get back to that
at some point in the future I just want
to make sure that the general layout of
the area is done at this point you can
always get back to the little fiddling
and tweaking some smaller things at some
point in the future but yeah that is
just about it for this episode because
I'm more or less running out of time
lapse to talk over here
so thank you guys for watching again and
I hope to see you next time